all right now listen
we just gave respect to anna kasparian
because she corrected the record on a
mistake she made and now i'm going to
highlight jank euger i'm not i'm not
someone who you know i typically don't
like talking about the young turks or
other commentators but this is actually
a really important um cultural moment
that we're getting not just from jack
yogurt but from one of his followers
that i think we absolutely need to
address
jenkuger tweeted
so joe rogan's show has now become a
boring right-wing show
no real diversity of opinion it's just
insane conspiracy theories and
right-wing lies like every other alex
jones and tucker carlson-like show and
it's obvious he doesn't want to be
challenged on his ideas anymore
the democrats just lost miserably in a
series of elections in virginia notably
due to critical race theory suburban
housewives white suburban women voted
for the republican critical race theory
plays poorly with you know working-class
individuals and suburbanites
we saw a state senator who spent only
153 dollars
win
without campaigning against the
incumbent democrat who refused to
concede until today's like okay i accept
that i lost because people just said
i'll take a ham sandwich if there's an r
next to it that's how much people are
fed up with the democrats with wokeness
with all of this stuff we've been
complaining about for a long time
if you look at
basically every metric you'll see that
independent voters are leaning closer
towards republicans simply because
republicans are closer to them and
democrats are going further and further
left
pew research put out a political tribes
chart
there is there is a group called the
stressed sideline which is the least
politically active group according to
their survey
center right position the individuals
who consider themselves to be
politically neutral are center right
we would probably fall under what pure
pure research refers to as the
ambivalent right they're not it's a
group of people who aren't conservative
but have voted republican who are
actually fairly progressive on certain
issues or or economic issues but are
against the democrats and wokeness and
all that stuff back to what genkuger is
saying and here's why i think it's so
important to highlight not just because
of his comment but because of one of his
followers responses who said i'm also
feeling that way about e cigar and
crystal ball with their breaking points
joe i loved it when they impartially
went after both sides of msm but now
it's just one-sided attacks and
conspiracy theories no balance anymore
my response was as democrats begin to
lose and moderates are shown to be
closer politically to the right because
the left has gone so far left a
breakdown among the left ensues
jenkuger's only responses because he's
built up his audience around chasing
this fringe unpopular ideology is
it's not me who's wrong
it's everyone else who just voted
against us and his followers says that's
right crystal ball and cigar who are
very like crystal balls progressive yeah
no no no they're far right now because
they're telling the truth yeah they're
breaking down yeah it's amazing i mean
we've been talking on this show for a
long time i've been talking about it
that the crt in schools is going to be
the biggest red pill delivery service
that we've seen and it clearly played
out that way you know we've been talking
about that pill deliveries about for two
years i mean when your daughter comes
home from school and wonders if she's a
racist because what they're talking
about in class you know that's going to
get mama bear activated and i also just
want to give some big shout outs to some
friends of ours corey deangelis
and christopher ruffo boy james lindsey
james lindsey of course and you know but
all of us here have been hammering all
this stuff for a long time uh and uh
dude they they had a huge hand in what
happened in virginia you know and and it
really shows and thank goodness because
i love virginia and i want it to be red
it really shows that what we need is a
it's a big network of people that aren't
necessarily on the same campaigns and
aren't necessarily getting paid by the
same people and aren't necessarily
totally aligned but you need people you
need the academics to define it you need
the media people to set the stage you
need the campaign managers to follow the
lead and follow the polls
and what happened in virginia was
amazing i was in orlando at the national
conservativism conference the night that
uh younkin won and chris ruffo was
sitting right next to me and when they
announced it oh man it was so exciting
because that dude has been busting his
ass but how crazy is it that here we are
you're democrat to deplorable being like
i want virginia to be red and i'm at the
conservatism i don't know i know and it
feels perfectly natural and those people
feel perfectly i mean i definitely did
not agree with everything that i heard
at the national conservative concert
however but they did feel more like
quote my people
and who would just interpret a random
event in a similar fashion than these
crazies like [ __ ] and dude like i'd i'd
gotten a media game later than you so i
have n i have never seen this jank
yogurt guy be
reasonable or or say anything smart or
whatever he's just been this buffoon you
should go back screaming and yelling at
some sort of idiot 2007 he was pretty
hard on george bush in the iraq war he
was a shining beacon speaking out
against it it was very nice he was
criticizing a lot of very powerful
forces many multinational corporations
he got a contract on msnbc msnbc tried
to stifle him and shut him up and he
said no
and he made it a huge issue he actually
stood up and got gained a lot of respect
from a lot of people and then ever since
then i think he's just been going
downhill and drinking some very strange
oddly smelling kool-aid and has gone off
the deep end money and views start
warping your mind too man they do this
is what happened to to all of these
establishment forces
um the young turks they were big they
were leftist
you have cnn who was supposedly the
corporate their corporate media for sure
but they were never hard left the way
they became what happened was especially
for the young turks is that
you go on twitter and you look at your
mentions and you get 30 replies and
you're scrolling down and they're all
saying you were wrong about x
people are easily manipulated by this
assuming that 30 angry people represent
their entire base
so what happens is eventually the young
turks and other you know digital outlets
start saying wow my followers think this
is right or they think this is wrong i
don't want to lose followers so they
started hearing to a fringe minority
we've seen the polling date it's been
eight between eight and ten percent of
the country if you want to abandon
ninety percent of the country for eight
percent because there's a market share
for you good luck what's happened now is
the young turks cnn msnbc have you seen
this they're losing all their talent
rachel maddow's cancelling her daily
show she's gonna do a weekly show and
brian williams announced he's leaving
because their ratings are in the trash
they have almost no key demo but they're
in the trash because of her
no no here's what happens
if you lie
for years russiagate they dedicated
themselves to being wrong
people are not the stupid clowns they
treat them out to be there are some
stupid clowns
but average people are average and
average people can see through lies they
understand that the square peg goes
through the square hole yeah so when
they come out and they say trump plead
with russia we know it for a fact
clapper goes on our show and says we've
all seen the evidence and then three
years later the report comes out trump
didn't those people go
the hell was i just watching and then
what happened their ratings collapsed
rachel maddow was nearly in tears but
she can't give it up why she lost
moderates who are looking for real news
she retained the cult members the young
turks have done the same thing now jank
huger's only option is to say joe rogan
who is moderate left leaning and the
most popular podcaster and probably the
second most popular comedian is far a
right wing boring show jank joe rogan is
like your average dude talking about
like crazy things all the time he's not
a tucker he's not tucker carlson he's
not a right-wing pundit
when i look at joe rogan i'm like that
should be your barometer for regular
people right the pulse of the nation
look at and and you look at his shows
when he goes and performs
people in new york show up for him these
are people in democrat strongholds
vaccines accepting the mandate
absolutely yeah and and so when i you
look at joe rogan and he is
very likely representing regular
americans but
the democrats have pulled you you look
at this the pew data that got released
that went viral when it shows the
democrat shift versus the republican
shift do you remember this the democrat
center has not become far left and the
republicans have moved like one point to
the right so republicans are closer to
where they've always been what happens
to a moderate or someone like a joe
rogan they look to their left and every
day they lie they cheat they steal and
they get further left and they look to
their right and there's a republican
saying the same thing they always did
and they're like the republican says the
fourth of july barbecue and christmas
are great i like those things too they
look to their left and they're like
you're white you're racist christmas is
racist shut up and they go okay that's
nuts right exactly you know this is why
if you're in journalism if you're in
media it's really important just to be
dedicated to the truth
right because then you just ask
questions and then you can be wrong
because you were never like i this is
what i believe you just you're just
asking questions i'm just the guy with
the microphone i'm just pulling on a
thread i mean that's my whole stick i
don't know really the answers to
anything i'm just asking questions
trying to figure it out and go where the
answers take you but that takes that
takes being able to withstand your
audience being mad at you
right and because if you just respond to
your audience being mad at you like uh
you know i catch a lot of crap for being
anti-trump i catch a lot of crap for a
lot of things but it's it's those
moments where you need to have some
fortitude because that's when you're
staying true to just the pursuit of
truth and that's why guys like mike
cernan gets so much crap from people
because he's just trying he's just
pursuing the truth his version of the
truth whatever he's just asking
questions and he's trying to come to his
own understanding it's when mad out dude
i said on november 7th donald trump lost
get over it yeah you need to move on and
all the hardcore trump supporters were
like you know screw to him pool they
were mad at me yeah but still the left
claims i pushed the narrative of
election fraud which i never did right
in fact steve bannon came on this show
and i i argued with him about it saying
i think you know you guys are focused on
the wrong thing you got to focus on
democrats ground game and how they did
voting in the park and how they did
universal mail-in voting because that is
the edge that got them the win
the left will still lie about me
so here's one of the challenges um
here's the example of the rittenhouse
case one of the challenges with
believing in america
the judge his ringtone was proud to be
an american yes
what does that mean it means he'll be
biased he's gonna say it's not good it
means he's biased for the left
for the left for the left
because he truly believes in the justice
system he's going to allow prosecutorial
misconduct because he wants there to be
a jury trial because the jury trial is
the american thing to do
so as the left the prosecutor lies
cheats and steals he'll say it is the
american value to give an equal
opportunity to everyone
you have people who raise their fist and
say long live the revolution their
explicit goal is to destroy this nation
and you are welcoming them to the fray
and giving them an opportunity i thought
about this and this is what you'll get
a a leftist revolutionary sect and
democratic establishment authoritarians
who will cheat and use your good faith
to continue doing it definitely so my
thought was kind of we should only
extend the values of our justice system
to those who uphold it equally for us as
well if we believe in the bill of rights
and the fifth amendment second amendment
why would we give people an opportunity
to take those rights from us what i mean
to say is if we believe in the right to
remain silent in a fair trial and
someone walks in and says i will not
give you that same benefit but i
demanded of you we should respond with
no either we all agree these are the
rules or we won't apply them to you if
you don't want them
to simplify even further if you don't
believe in free speech why would i
defend your right to free speech you
don't believe in it i'll give you the
respect you've asked for
that's a tough one man the issue is
i mean i hear what you're saying i hear
what you're saying but like the right to
yeah
that's tough
so but those are the most egregious
circumstances that free speech has to be
supported yeah it's even for people that
don't believe in it right even for
people that are acting insane for people
that are doing the dumbest craziest
things that you could possibly think of
yeah then that's why guys like mark
randazza are amazing because they go out
there and defend those kind of people i
agree but there's a line yeah so i i
there there are a few been a few pundits
who have pointed out that one of the
problems with conservatives and the more
libertarian-minded people on free speech
is that they're unwilling to accept any
limitations on speech in pursuit of free
speech which is the wrong thing to do
well we need to recognize that there are
certain limits culturally that we're not
willing to accept and then call out the
left for violating these same limits and
not respecting the free speech that they
demand
to put it simply there's that paradox of
intolerance where they say if you
tolerate intolerance then the intolerant
win and that's not
necessarily untrue
we all need to agree on the rules and
then operate within those rules if
someone seeks to destroy our rights and
attack our way of life we should not
you know uh give them you know equal
opportunity we should not open the door
for them to put it simply
wrap this all up my point is
the judge in the written house case
knows they're breaking the rules has
yelled at the prosecutors but it's still
as someone who believes in america an
american is proud will uphold these
systems which benefit those who lie
cheat and steal and are seeking to
destroy the very system that is
protecting them
it is a paradox
it just means that
we can't be absolute in our defense of
um egregious actors we certainly will
protect their free speech and act in
good faith but when it becomes apparent
that they're trying to destroy the
system we say okay we can't tolerate
your attempt to destroy free speech d so
that logic do the
9 11 suicide bombers do they deserve a
free like a fair trial absolutely okay
so
i think what i mean to say is
uh and i think you know ian helped my
understanding of this he had some good
questions about the ethics of vaccine
lockdown of mandates and lockdowns when
you brought up ebola and what people's
rights are
there's a point where if there was an
airborne ebola everyone in this room
would be like lock it all down right
like an 80 mortality of people coughing
and their insides are liquefying and
you're watching it happen we'd all be
like lock it we'd be freaking out yeah
but to varying degrees so then you know
i started to think that for the most
part it's really about how much risk
you're how much you're willing to
tolerate in terms of sacrificing
freedoms because everybody's willing to
give up something if it if something is
you know give us some of their freedoms
if it's egregious enough i think for the
most part we just happen to be people
who watch the show and us substantially
more libertarian than they are
so they're more more likely uh to take
away people's rights we won't we won't
tolerate that but a really good point
that was made that i think helps will
help people understand this is that
someone said to tucker carlson
you would not allow someone to come on
your show and make racist comments and
tucker said you are correct he's like
right we agree there are limits on
acceptable speech
it's a good point
the legal limits should not be banning
hate speech but the culturally
acceptable limits exist in which case we
need to enforce culturally our ideals
and tell people who would say revolution
nothing less by any means necessary that
we will not accept
that that culture thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 p.m and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you